Count Dooku was a visionary.
He was cut short in his time by the Jedi
Do it
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This'll be my Full Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 6 Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
It was like Cameo City.
There were so many big actors
cameo in this.
If you're bringing new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
And careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode title
Guns for Hire is a reference to Boka Tanz
Night Owls, mostly who return for
the first time since the end of season two
and we find out what happened to them.
Simon cast Sasha Banks
came back as Cast Wolves and Casca.
Reeves
And we meet a whole bunch more of them,
like they're a bunch of night owls there.
But remember,
this is just meant to be one group
of the mandalorians
that she's been sent to reunite.
But of course, the first place
she would go to would be to her
former night owls.
Previously, Bo-Katan
had explained to Mando in Episode
one that they'd become privateers
after abandoning her
at the end of season two
when she returned without the darksaber
which they pay off
at the end of this episode too.
And they just been using
all the imperial ships
that they commandeered during season two
and before the events of season two
to work as mercenaries.
The episode was directed by Bryce Dallas
Howard.
If you didn't watch The Tales of the Jedi
episodes, Bryce Dallas Howard is also now
the canon voice of Seattle,
who does not speak the backwards speech
like Yoda speaks normally,
I guess word travels fast.
Wow. Or statements to the council
rather surprising.
Oh wait, put your
weapon. I mean, you know how
I am wondering why are you here?
Apparently, Yoda is the only being
of his race who speaks like that,
confirming that when Grogu, who does
eventually speak like a normal person,
like speaks basic, he'll speak normally.
The actual opening scene
is of a Korean ship traveling to traverse
the same planet that Mando met Bo-Katan
in the Night Owl was on.
There's a lot of references
of that episode in a lot of music cues,
like a lot of theme music
for that episode.
Towards the end of this episode,
that was the planet
that he was taking Frog Lady
to where the other core and were working
because it was an aquatic planet,
which is their natural environment,
their homeworld is Mon Cal,
just like the Mon Calamari race,
which they referenced
during this opening scene.
They're originally
from the same planet in there.
Peoples have just been at war for a long
time, but this is why the Korean ship
has similar design language
to the Mon calamari capital ships there.
Captain Shaggath is played by Christine
Adams,
who's from Black Lightning,
rejuvenating inside a water tank.
This isn't meant to be like
a medical doctor tank. It's just there.
Species needs water
like a fish needs water.
She only needs to use it occasionally,
as we see.
Right after this one, she deactivates it
while addressing the Mandalorians on Moff
Gideon, the former Imperial cruiser,
When she thinks that they are
still Imperials, they even have
that little joke about her junior officer.
Bring her a little snack of some fish
which he pours into her
tank like, Here, have a little bite.
The reason they have this tank on
the bridge is so that she doesn't
have to leave the bridge
to stay properly hydrated.
She could just do all the functions
of being a captain,
stay near all the critical systems
while she's rejuvenating the imperial ship
that they come upon.
Winds up being Moff Gideon,
a former imperial cruiser
that's being piloted by cast bows
and costa trees.
The other night, our Mandalorian,
and we find out what they've been doing
this whole
time, paying off Bo-Katan Earlier,
a conversation with Mando in episode one.
They've just been hiring themselves out
as muscle to anyone
who will pay their price
when she says her native language
isn't basic, That's the common tongue.
Like the Star Wars word for English.
The Cuaron's native language
is called colonies that I speak.
My mother got over my knee
or gut the bow tie, and this
they played for big reveals
the most. You probably realize
what was going on before
they actually showed them on screen.
They say they were hired
by the Mon Calamari King, to find his son,
who's played by Harry Holland.
Another big cameo,
Tom Holland, Spider-Man's real brother
in the Marvel movies
that had run away with the Korean
because of a very Romeo and Juliet,
Montagues and Capulets, forbidden romance
twists like the Mon Calamari was in love
with the corn.
Their parents were trying to disallow it
by force,
by hiring the night owls to bring it back.
The whole conflict there
between their two people is the Mon
Calamari.
The corn in the star crossed lovers
is also meant to be a metaphor
for all the Mandalorian clans
coming together again.
Warring cultures from a single planet
that are trying to find a way
to actually get along with each other
and find peace.
When he says they're very good
at what they do, they're very loyal.
That's also a reference to the whole way
their culture works,
like when Bo-Katan beats
cast wolves in combat.
The other mandalorians
the night owls agree to follow her again,
and when she fulfills the terms of winning
the darksaber like per their culture,
she technically owns the darksaber
they agreed to be loyal to her again.
They also use this as a bit of a joke
to look a bit of a dark twist
when Coscarelli says we're loyal, all it
takes is a few credits to buy our loyalty.
Basically, I think that might be a sly
wink at what happened with Moff Gideon,
because there's still a lot of questions
about who saves him, who rescued him,
Was it his dark troopers?
And did those dark troopers
just have a beskar alloy shell?
And that's why
it was embedded in the hole?
Or was it another group of bad
mandalorians like evil Mandalorians
whose allegiance
had been purchased by Moff Gideon
Maybe you can also look at the whole star
crossed lovers thing from warring cultures
as being a reference
to Mando and Bo-Katan,
but they haven't really done anything
with their relationship arc recently.
Like they had the whole darksaber
arc at the end of the episode,
but that really didn't have anything to do
with their actual relationship.
Even though right after this,
when you see them
for the first time in the episode,
the vibe feels a lot like space.
Dad in space,
Mom taking the kid on a field trip,
like the three of them
have become this family unit.
You're now a clan of three.
When he says
their next contract is on Plaisir 15.
That's the Pleasure Planet where Bo-Katan
and Mando are going with Grogu you.
I'm guessing there's a bit of a time
jump in Bo-Katan just learned
that the night Owls had gone to Plaza 15.
When you actually see them, you notice
that Grogu, who is sitting right
next to her, like
literally right next to her up in front,
and she starts talking to him.
Katee Sackhoff
also saw some funny stories about this
between takes when they were filming.
She would also talk to the Grogu
Doll, just say casual things to it.
But she didn't realize that the puppeteers
mikes were still active.
So the puppeteers that were operating
the Grogu doll
could hear everything that she was saying.
So the Grogu doll would start reacting
to everything
that she was saying, freaking her out
just a little bit.
But Grogu was sitting so close to her
is a sign of how close he's grown to her,
metaphorically and literally,
how much he trusts her, like now,
because he's starting to think of her
as his surrogate mother
the same way that he thinks of Mando
as his surrogate father.
That's why I keep making the jokes about
how Bo-Katan is becoming his space mom.
We find out that the night owls have been
hired for protection for the planet
because per the New Republic's charter,
they aren't allowed to have their own
native military force.
They have a fairly large fleet,
which we see later in the episode,
mostly imperial ships,
all stolen under Bo-Katan
leadership in previous seasons
and before the events of season one
in the whole domed city
is meant to give you a vibe
for the Mandalore planet,
like the Dome Cities of Mandalore
foreshadowing the whole idea that they're
going to retake the planet very soon.
They're greeted the spaceport
by a very dark R2-D2 and C-3PO.
Reference like these are meant to be.
A dark twist on
the main are two and three per unit,
but is actually an RJ seven droid.
He's also known as the Death Star Droid
because these models were used
on the Death Star.
It appeared a couple times
during A New Hope,
which Mando comments on saying,
Why are there
so many imperial droids here?
But it's all part of the New Republic
amnesty program,
and they're trying to rehabilitate
all these former imperial assets.
Imperial people.
The droid that was manning the PR system
references the course and accords.
Again, this is the second time
those are the accords that were signed
as part of the formation
of the New Republic
after Return of the Jedi,
all the planets in the galaxy
that wanted to join the New Republic
and gain access to all of its support and
trade would have had to sign the accords,
basically agreed to all the rules
of being part of the New Republic.
This game their chain codes.
Remember, we saw those during season two
when Boba Fett showed Mando his chain
code, proving that he was a mandalorian,
also setting out the twist
at the end of the episode
where they find out that the chain code
belongs to Christopher Lloyd's character,
who is a former separatist.
But before they can confront
the night owls who they're here to see,
they're summoned to the Capitol by Jack
Black and Lizo,
who are playing
the administrators of the planet.
The entire area here, the architecture,
the vibe is just meant to be reminiscent
of Lando's Cloud City,
when Han Solo, Chewbacca, Princess Leia,
The others went there and at first
it seemed like a weirdly hostile
but super nice place. Like well-kept.
And gradually the situation
turned against them
as they discovered that the Empire
Darth Vader had set a trap for them.
Just like Christopher Lloyd's separatist
character was trying to set a trap,
take over the planet with the droids.
And because we had the quadrant
at the beginning of the episode,
you could call this like a big payoff
on the Admiral Ackbar meme.
It's a trap.
Just like the trap that Darth Vader laid
for Luke Skywalker and his friends.
It's a trap.
In fact, later in the episode,
Christopher Lloyd's character even
almost references Alnwick and Skywalker
before he's cut off short.
We meet Jack Black and Lizzo,
who are the leaders of the planet.
There's so many guest
stars in the episode.
Jack Black is also playing Bowser
literally right now in the Super Mario
Brothers movie, just came out in theaters
so good timing on that.
Maybe I'll do a video for that later
this week.
The huge banquet here is another reference
to Darth Vader's invitation
in the Empire Strikes Back
that we would be so glad if you joined us.
We would be honored if you would join us.
There's a bunch of familiar creatures
at the banquet,
but the one in the floating tank
seemed new.
It did seem kind of like a reference
to Dune in the space navigators.
He makes a banter joke
like address the elephant in the room.
But we're talking about Panthers
because this is Star Wars.
In the way he explains his backstory.
They imply
Jack Black's character used to be
an imperial facilities planning officer
during the original trilogy.
When he says the war,
he means the Galactic Civil War
between the Empire and the Rebellion.
He also went through
the same New Republic amnesty program.
You see, he's still wearing the same pin
on his jacket.
Elliott Cain and Dr.
Pershing,
where in at the end of the episode,
Christopher Lloyd's character also implies
that he's just as corrupt as Elliot
Kane is, only pretending
that he's been rehabilitated
like it takes at the end of the episode.
But they do play it a little bit like this
meant to be a bit of doubt
about his honesty.
Like is he trying to take advantage
of his position, making Lizzo believe
that he's in love with her
or he's actually being genuine?
Jack Black tends to play
a lot of characters like that.
You wonder where their allegiance lies.
Are they telling the truth
or are they telling you a lie?
But part of this amnesty program,
the whole idea that you're meant
to question
where their true allegiances lie
is why you see all the stormtrooper
gear all over the place
like a bunch of the troops
are wearing stormtrooper armor
without the helmets.
The whole question is
whether or not this New Republic
amnesty program actually works,
because for the most part,
it kind of doesn't seem like it works
based on the last couple of episodes,
which does support the idea
that Jack Black's character
is also being kind of shady.
Lizzo's
character is meant to be the daughter
of the previous ruler of the planet.
It seems like she's meant to be genuinely
a good person and not totally complicit.
If Jack Black's character
is doing something shady,
they agree to set up a meeting
with the Night Owls.
But first ask them to solve their little
droid army problem, which we get to.
Christopher Lloyd Storyline
Got a little problem
with a couple battle droids when she says
We thought they were rehabilitated,
but they were not.
That's also a reference to Elliot
Kane only pretending to be rehabilitated.
Also the same with Christopher Lloyd's
character too,
because he was only pretending
to be part of these different governments.
But he'd been a loyal to the separatists
the whole time.
You also notice
how formal they get here too.
When Jack Black's character calls Bo-Katan
Princess Kreis, another callback to her
being the true princess of Mandalore,
the ruler of Mandalore,
which she talked about with Mando earlier
when she was a little girl.
She grew up in the ruling family,
so technically, Katie Sackhoff is kind of
like a Disney princess. Now.
If you see her at any conventions or
any signings, you can ask her about this.
I'm sure she has some thoughts about it.
They said of the whole Grogu storyline,
like they had to do something with him
during the episode.
Well, they're busy trying to find out
what's going on with the droids
and he stays with the lizard.
So the whole idea that she wins him
over quickly by promising treats
and when you really think about it, Grogu
will probably do
just about anything to get a treat.
Also important, though, for their grand
plan of retaking Mandalore,
they also offer their help to Bo-Katan
in getting the New Republic to recognize
Mandalore as a sovereign system again,
making it legitimate in their eyes,
which would benefit them greatly,
especially if they wound up
in a giant conflict, a giant war
with the remnants of the Empire
like Grand Admiral Thrawn and Moff Gideon.
They made a big deal about that in last
week's episode with Tim Meadows character.
Like, Oh, you know the planet. It's
not part of The New Republic.
Well, you know,
we really don't have time to help them.
When she asks Mando
how he feels about things,
I love his reaction to
he says, You have me a battle droids.
You had me at
Battle Droids because Mando hates droids.
He would love any opportunity
to try and stick it to them.
We meet Christopher Lloyd's character,
like the next major cameo in a cameo
heavy episode
who's playing the head of security.
The plan.
His name is Hell Gate,
which with a name like that, no wonder
he winds up being the true
villain of the episode.
It'd be like a movie naming
someone Captain Evil guy.
I wonder who's going to be the bad person
here?
Oh, probably the evil guy, he says.
All the former imperial droids
and separatist droids on the planet
were taken originally from the ones
that were going to be scrapped at Cadogan.
That's the same planet during season two,
where Bill Burr's character
had been sent to work
The tale in The New Republic.
We're scrapping tons of stuff,
even going back to the Clone Wars
and the separatists when they show
the montage of the droids rebelling,
you see a bunch of different ones.
There's B1 battle droids from the prequels
from Clone Wars.
This Land Speeder
seems like a souped up, nicer version
of Luke Skywalker's land speeder.
They also have a chef droid, which we saw
in episode one on the streets in Navarro.
And even though Christopher Lloyd's
character is withholding information
because he's behind all these attacks,
he's not wrong when he says the reason
why he didn't shut down all the droids
is because the people of the planet
have become dependent on them,
because the droids do all the work.
This is part of the idea
that even though he is meant to be
the villain of the episode
because he's a separatist,
he's trying to take over the planet.
When he says
the planet has become corrupt, everyone's
grown fat and lazy
and no one wants to work anymore.
He's being truthful about that.
Also, the other side reason
why he didn't press the button is because
that was like a failsafe device
which would cause all the battle droids
to revert to their former programing
and really start going after everyone.
Like there are a couple of reasons why I'm
not pressing this giant red button here.
They have another clause that he Empire
Strikes Back referenced when they travel
to the lower levels to get help
from the juggernauts, Empire Strikes Back.
They've also been relegated to menial work
in the bowels of the city.
There's even a more direct reference
to that
when you see the pieces of the C-3PO droid
in the background here,
like the ones in Empire Strikes Back
when they found Threepio in pieces, Mando
makes a couple more cracks
about why you shouldn't trust droids,
why he hates them with a few exceptions
like IG 11 and now r5d4,
even though technically are five D
for kind of sold them out to Carson
Taylor's character.
Ultimately that wound up
leading to something good though
in the have nots workshop, they have
a bunch of the larger super battle droids.
There's a couple other Easter eggs too.
Like this
droid actually seems like the same model
as the Droid from the Jedi ship
in Clone Wars
who held the designs of every single
lightsaber that had ever been created.
Now, obviously, it's not the exact same
droid, it's just the same type of model.
Mando wins their help with a big callback
mentioning Quill the oh,
not from season one,
saying their catchphrase I have spoken,
which makes it sound like that's
a bigger part of their culture.
And it wasn't just something cool
that Quill would do on his own.
The ignites reveal
what's really been happening.
There's nothing wrong with the droids.
They're not rebelling.
It was Christopher Lloyd's character
ultimately, who was forcing them to wreak
havoc on the city
with nano droids from the techno union.
Another big prequels reference.
They do play this for a little comedy
to like their interpersonal dynamics,
with Mando acting as the point man
like the true diplomat,
because Bo-Katan
has either lost her patience
or has no patience for diplomacy to begin
with.
But she does do a pretty decent job
at the end of the episode.
So I think when the situation demands
that she can be the diplomat,
Bo-Katan references the Clone Wars again
when seeing all the battle droids
because she was featured so heavily
in the Clone Wars episodes, Mando
saying that he's also seen the Battle
Droids is a callback to his childhood
when he was rescued by the death
Watch Mandalorians
originally while
his village was being attacked
by the Battle droids
during the Clone Wars,
which they also reference again
at the end of the episode
when Cas Wos tries to tell him that he's
not a true mandalorian because he wasn't
born Mandalorian in Bo-Katan sets him
straight, saying Being a mandalorian
isn't about your blood, it's
about the Creed's about walking
the way of the true Mandalore
Maybe at some point
we'll get some more mando flashbacks.
We haven't really seen his childhood
too much,
but we don't get that much time
during episodes.
The voice of this Battle
droid is the same voice of the prequels
in the Clone Wars
episodes like the same voice of all Battle
Droids is basically Matthew.
Would they do try to do that?
Would they bring characters back
who did voices for
very common characters during the prequels
or during the Clone Wars episodes?
It's a little bit easier
to bring someone back
like that from the older
episodes of the older movies
when it's just a voiceover, a cameo.
Mando tests them out
by kicking them around because remember,
he hates droids, so he kind of enjoys
what's happening here.
Finding one that has been reprogramed
by the nanobots, which starts
attacking them, starting a big Mando chase
scene with Bo-Katan through the city.
A lot of the big action scenes
and pretty much
all the episodes, not just this episode,
but all episodes are just meant to be Jon
Favreau and Dave Filoni showing off
what they can do with special effects.
Now, if you go back
and you watch the previous
episodes, that's
why all the different action
scenes seem like they are meant to evolve
from previous seasons.
And during the different episodes,
they try to show you
very different types of action scenes,
like there were a lot of city based action
scenes
and big chase scenes in this episode.
Also some really cool Mandalorian
on Mandalorian
fight scenes too, like some red
hot jetpack on jetpack action.
You have to imagine Jon Favreau
and Dave Filoni storyboarding episodes,
planning out ideas,
just playing with their action figures
when they're running through the city.
You see a bunch of the different types
of droids references, the prequels.
A couple of them seem like newer models,
but most of them are deep cuts
for either the prequels movies
or for the original trilogy.
These droids seem like
the newer version of the 99 droids.
There are a bunch of them in the episode.
There's also a mouse droid
that they run past another droid
that was on the desk
star More Imperial Droids.
Remember,
there's another one of these souped up
versions of Luke Skywalker's Land Speeder.
They have the same
hot rod looking speeder bikes
that they use in the book of Boba Fett.
On tattooing.
They actually said
that these were actually supposed
to be a reference to the cars
in George Lucas's American Graffiti movie.
That was the movie that he did
before he did Star Wars
also starred a very young Harrison Ford.
When they eventually chase it
down, these droids that show up,
the floaty ones are just called
Constable Droids.
They find a spark pad
which leads them to the droids only bar,
which obviously is a big joke
on a new hope.
The line in the cantina,
We don't serve their kind here,
but here they only serve their kind.
Also, the whole name of the bar,
the resistor is meant to be a reference
to mechanical resistors like you would put
in a machine like droids, in the idea
of resisting rebelling because that's
the whole theme of the episode,
rebelling droids.
As they walk into the bar, there's another
God droid behind them in the alleyway.
All the droids in here in
there are many of them are Easter eggs
and references
deep cuts for the original trilogy.
The prequels.
Seriously,
there are so many Easter eggs in here.
Zoom in and hands all over the room.
Here they have another chef droid.
The bartender is one of those
other more advanced 99 droids,
which I think is meant to be a callback
to 99 from the original trilogy,
being the new bartender
in the most Eisley Cantina.
You remember that scene was actually
a stealth cameo scene for Mark Hamill,
who was doing the Voice of the 99.
You wouldn't have recognized it
unless they told you, though.
Like, it didn't sound like Mark Hamill.
I'm not sure where these droids appeared
before, but they seem familiar.
This one is the same model
the great cargo was using.
He's based on the original Ralph
McQuarrie concept art for C-3PO,
just done in silver
on the left here and in the background
is a Z droid from a New Hope.
There actually featured a couple of times
during a new hope, like
there were a pair of droids
that got separated in the desert.
That's how one wound up in the job was.
And crawler
in another wound up in Mos Eisley, walking
past Luke Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Then one was also played
by Anthony Daniels, who does do a lot of
still cameo scenes as protocol droids.
Not always C-3PO droids,
but other droids like C-3PO.
In the back, there's a blue C-3PO,
a yellow R five battle droids,
and the one with the red eyes
looks familiar.
But I can't remember exactly
which movie they used him in.
So if you think you know right up below
in the comments, there's two R2 units.
The white Droid is the same model
that was interrogating or talking to Dr.
Pershing as part of his rehabilitation.
And the one behind him is another black,
a seven death star droid.
They have another classic 99 Droid
talking to one of the newer versions.
These are more of the same Jedi
ship droids in the background.
And when Mando and Bo-Katan go out,
good cop, bad cop on the bartender droid.
I think that's meant to be a callback
to EB 99 and job as Palace, threatening
C-3PO and R2-D2 that if they didn't
comply, they would be tortured.
Some master got angry
with our last protocol
droid and his team to break,
so there's a couple of the classic Wrex
star tour droids.
And there's another gang droid.
There's a couple random ones here too
that I can't totally place.
So if you think you recognize some of
these, post them in the comments below.
They make another Clone Wars
reference to the separatists
in the way
he explains that the bartender droids is
most of the droids like these old droids
that have been rehabilitated
on the planet or eager
for the second chance in redemption,
which is also
the journey that Bo-Katan is on right now.
It's meant to be a parallel for her
redeeming herself
in uniting all Mandalorians, he explains.
The droids
only consume something called Nepenthe.
They that's actually
a fictional medication
that appears in Allan Poe's
The Raven, also in Greek mythology,
within the context of the Edgar
Allan Poe story.
It's a concoction
which would cause the writer in that story
to lose memory of his lost love.
Within the context of the episode, though,
the substance actually reprograms
the droids because it's been poisoned
with the nanobots from the techno union,
and that's what's been causing them
to rebel to resist another call
back to the name of the bar, the resistor.
Christopher Lloyd separatist
character has a very dark sense of humor
that he's using the resistor bar
to do this.
When they go to get more information,
they're using a former interrogation
droid painted white,
which reverts to his former programing.
Attacking them
Mando destroys it with the darksaber
whipping it out
for the first time in a while.
It also doesn't feel heavy in his hands.
He didn't have any trouble using it
like he did earlier.
Lot of people asking about why this is,
and that's because of the way
the Darksaber works.
Because you're talking about the force
here.
It's just another kind of lightsaber.
The blade responds
to the motions of the wielder,
so the more sure of your actions,
the more sure of your purpose,
the easier it is for people to wield it.
The reason
why Mando had trouble using it sometimes
is because he had doubt about his actions.
He wasn't sure what he was trying to do
or what his path was here.
When he's just reacting automatically
trying to save Bo-Katan and the other girl
here because he's so sure of himself,
it's much easier for him to use.
It is also why Bo-Katan has such an easy
time using it when she was saving Mando
because she was very sure of what she was.
She's very clear of purpose.
It doesn't really have anything to do with
Bo-Katan or Mando being force sensitive.
You don't actually need to be forced
sensitive to use the Darksaber,
but him whipping it out is also meant
to foreshadow the end of the episode too.
When he gives it to Bo-Katan,
they follow the trail.
Back to Christopher
Lloyd's Helgi character
who had ordered the nanobots
from the techno union that were illegal
because he's still a separatist,
forcing the droids to revolt
because he felt like
the planet had become corrupt.
And when they confront him on it,
he explains that he'd always hated
the former republic
like we're talking about
before the prequels, claiming
that they were corrupt government.
The Empire was also a corrupt government,
and it sounds like he also probably thinks
The New Republic is just as bad,
revealing that he had stayed loyal
to the separatist movement
this entire time, even after their defeat
during the Clone Wars.
It is not wrong, though.
The Republic had grown corrupt,
the Empire was also corrupt in watching
the last few episodes, The New Republic
doesn't seem that much better.
His whole speech about supporting true
democracy, the ideals of the separatists
is a callback to count Dooku
who started the separatists.
We literally references
calling him a visionary.
If you watch the Tales of the Jedi
episodes, big callback to Bryce, Dallas
Howard to a bit of an Easter egg
because she directed this episode,
she also does the voice of Seattle,
who's very critical to count Dooku story
during Tales of the Jedi.
It tells the story
of how Count Dooku fell to the dark side
and what happened to battle ultimately.
But during that you see Count
Dooku is arc in
why he started the separatists
in the first place.
The whole idea is that Count Dooku
had good intentions, like he felt like
the Republic had become corrupt
and they needed a better government.
But Emperor Palpatine
took advantage of that in the separatist
became pawns in his plan
to take over the galaxy.
So in a sense, Christopher
Lloyd's character believes in good things.
He just said terrible things
in service of those ideals.
We'll probably continue
to see a lot of that
from different characters
on both sides of things,
like the former empire,
the people that are part
of the New Republic right now.
And then Bo-Katan takes him out, right
as he's about to reference.
And again, Skywalker,
when he was about to say Count
Dooku was literally and metaphor thickly
cut down by the Jedi enforcer.
And again, Skywalker like he literally cut
his hands off and then cut his head off.
Do it.
When we go back to Jack Black and Liz's
characters, it seems that they're
playing the Star Wars
version of Croquet with Living Creatures,
and that felt like a reference
to Alice in Wonderland,
where the Queen of Hearts
use living Creatures to play croquet
with a little bit of help from Goku
using the force to allow her to win.
When they confront
Christopher Lloyd's character again,
he uses the same expression,
the character calling the stippling slimy.
Boba Fett used that insult
during season two.
CAD Bane also used that term
during the book of Boba Fett.
Oh, look, that isn't quite calling
this differing slimy.
If that's not the actor calling this
just waiting slimy.
Seriously, at some point we're going
to need a Star Wars book of slang.
He calls out Jack Black for perverting
plaisir 15 since arriving,
implying that he's still imperial.
Kind of like Elliott, Kane is still
technically loyal to the Imperials.
The Moon Park cat that they exile him to
is also a brand new place in the Star Wars
universe
that they created for the episode.
You notice
that when Lizzo is addressing them,
she addresses Mando
as being from Concordia, a formal title,
because they're going to make good
on their offer
to help legitimize
the Mandalorians claim to Mandalore.
Maybe at some point
we'll see a flashback to Concordia, too.
They also give them the key to the city.
I actually expected Bo-Katan
to beat Consuelos with that.
Like beat him silly with the actual key,
but I guess they didn't
want to be that on the nose with it.
When she says they'll always be
welcome here in the city, I think
she's also foreshadowing that bo-katan
the mando will come back to get the og
nots help with their IG 11 droid problem
because during the episode several times
they reference
how the OG nods are renowned
for their droid work
when she invites Grogu
to part of their ancient order.
Obviously that's meant to be a reference
to him becoming a Jedi Knight,
even though he's also becoming
a Mandalorian right now.
And it kind of seems like he left
the Jedi order rewarded for his help
in her winning the games.
The sword design
and the hilt look kind of familiar.
So if you think you recognize
where this blade
or the hilt comes from in some other movie
post in the comments below,
when they meet the Night Owls,
they played the Night Owls theme song
from season two.
You see Moff Gideon
Cruiser, the Imperial Transport
that he also stole in that same episode.
Season two, Episode
three In a couple of smaller Mandalorian
fighters like the one Bo-Katan flies.
Also, when Bo-Katan challenges castmates
for leadership, the music they play for
the fight is also the same music track
they use in their mission.
In season two, Episode three,
it winds up being a pretty solid fight.
Like the fight
choreography is pretty good.
They want to show you what it looks like
when a couple of mandalorians
fight each other using all their different
Mandalorian tech like the jetpacks,
the grappling hooks,
the flamethrowers, the energy shields.
And after she beats him,
he throws the darksaber in her face,
trying to get her to challenge Mando
for it.
In combat, Manu tries to slide it
through on a technicality
and technically he is not wrong.
The scavenger defeated him
even though it was an honorable combat.
He lost the darksaber then
and she won it from the scavenger,
even though technically
she picked it up off the ground.
Like I said, they're playing it real fast
and loose
kind of a technicality, so you could
question the legitimacy of this.
But I think in the episode,
the whole idea is that
they want to unite all these mandalorians
by the end of the season.
So they, in the episode,
wanting you to think
that she owns the Darksaber rightfully,
she gives them a really great rally speech
about how they need to all follow the way
to take Mandalore to become one people.
They'll be much stronger
together than apart
in generally reminds them
about what it is to be a true mandalorian.
It isn't so much about where you're born
into is all about the creed
in following the true way
of the ancient Mandalore
in when Mando actually
physically gives her the Darksaber
that's meant to be a direct callback
to the Star Wars Rebels episode, where
Sabine Wren gave Bo-Katan the Darksaber
and it was a very similar type of reaction
to where a bunch of mandalorians
were rallying together.
And for all of mandalore
you have
to remember though, this is just one
group of Mandalorians
these are just the night owls.
There are many groups of Mandalorians
there are only two episodes left,
so we'll probably find out
about some of the other groups
in next week's episode.
We also got to find out
what really happened to Moff Gideon.
There's still lots of theories about that.
We had to find out what happened to Dr.
Pershing, what's going on with Elliott
Cain, and they have to actually physically
go back to Mandalore the planet,
all of them, including the armors group.
So feel like they'll have at least one
episode to explain fully what's going on
with Moff Gideon on his side of things,
the empire side of things.
It's grand.
Admiral Thrawn in another episode
like the finale where they have
all of the Mandalorians coming together
on Mandalore where you see the mythos, or
if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
There were a bunch of prequels
references in the episode
I'll do a Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 7 Trailer video
that should post in the next day
In my full Episode 7 video
we'll post next week
after they release it.
There were a bunch of other trailers
that I'm still working on.
There's a bunch of stuff
that happened this week,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click here for that Episode 7 video
after the link as soon as I posted
and click here
for all My Mandalorian episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way!